-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
At a campaign reception
in New York yesterday,
President Biden said
that former President Trump
is an existential threat
to the country.
Not to be rude,
but we know, dude.
[ Laughter ]
That was the original
title of this show.
[ Laughter ]
The Super Bowl is this weekend.
Some people will root
for the Chiefs,
some for the 49ers,
but everybody will be
rooting for Taylor's plane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on...Taylor's plane.
House Democrats
yesterday kicked off
their three-day
strategy retreat in Virginia,
and the theme for this year's
event is "Finish the Job."
And Mike Pence
is really hoping
that's also not
the Republicans' theme.
[ Laughter ]
When asked yesterday
why he brought the vote
to impeach Homeland Security
Secretary Alejandro Mayorkas
to the floor if he did not have
the votes to pass it,
House Speaker Mike Johnson
said that "people show up
when they're not expected
to be in the building."
Yeah, that's a problem.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic candidate Marianne
Williamson announced yesterday
that she has ended
her presidential campaign.
She'll now go back
to her day job,
which I think is
ending presidential campaigns.
[ Laughter ]
California's senate's candidates
are set to debate later
this month at Universal Studios
in Hollywood,
where one is going to have
home court advantage.
[ Laughter ]
Shrek.
Former Fox News host Tucker
Carlson tonight
released his interview
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin,
where he asked him all the tough
questions like,
"Do you like me?" and
"Okay, but do you think
you could like me?"
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Senator
Kirsten Gillibrand
hosted a bipartisan
bowling night this week
at the White House,
and there was an awkward moment
when someone mistook
John Fetterman for the guy
who repairs the equipment.
[ Laughter ]
Lawmakers in New Mexico
are considering
making drive-up
marijuana sales legal.
Until then, you'll just have
to wait until Brad's working.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, yeah, yeah,
here's your quarter pounder..."
A Florida man was arrested
during a recent traffic stop
after authorities
discovered cocaine,
crystal meth, and marijuana --
or, as it's called in Florida,
a balanced breakfast.
[ Laughter ]
The Margaritaville at Sea
cruise line
has announced
that it will expand
its Heroes Sail Free program
for first responders.
'Cause if you're going on
a Margaritaville-themed cruise,
you're going to want
some first responders there.
[ Laughter ]
A man in France was recently
denied the Guinness World Record
for largest matchstick tower,
after he spent eight years
building his model
of the Eiffel Tower
using the wrong matches.
Aw, no!
So you mean
that huge waste of time
turned out to be
a giant waste of time?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities
at the Fort Lauderdale airport
recently arrested a man
who allegedly parked his car
on the sidewalk
and then walked through
the terminal fully nude.
Because Florida cops
will put up with a lot,
but you just can't park
on the sidewalk.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We are off and running.